Jim and I are just too similar
maybe one day I'll find my own Karen but
you know that is a you know not a man a
man version but uh until then I can hold
my head up I'm not gay I don't know I
feel about hiring a Sixers fan I should
leave let me ask you a question Jim
you're clearly a very bright guy Thanks
always hit your numbers personable you
make a great impression on everyone you
meet I'm sorry wait so was the question
how did I get to be so awesome good I
don't have an answer for you oh hey do
you have your quarterly numbers yes
absolutely the questionnaire sorry to
make you fill that thing no no
absolutely to our formality we have this
very irritating HR guy here it's
probably the only person you're not
gonna like Kendall so first up there
yeah how do you think you function here
in New York what's that oh great you
know I just I really appreciate the
buildings and the people and there's
just an energy that New York has not to
mention they have places that are open
past 8:00 so that's a bonus you've been
in the Scranton branch a long time what
have you liked most about that place the
friendships okay well we want the person
who takes his position to be here for
the long haul so long haul where do you
see yourself in 10 years
how are your feet medium rare
Thanks the real reason that I went to
Stanford was because I wanted to be not
here I know
and even though I came back
I just feel like I've never really come
back
well I wish you would
dunder-mifflin this is Pam
I just went moment I'll transfer you I
haven't heard anything but I'd bet Jim
got the job I mean why wouldn't he he's
totally qualified and smart everyone
loves him and if he never comes back
again that's okay we're friends and I'm
sure we'll stay friends
we just we never got the timing right
you know I shot him down and then he did
the same to me and but you know what
it's okay
I am totally fine everything is gonna be
totally sorry are you free for dinner
tonight
yes all right then it's a date
I'm sorry what was the question
hey I wasn't sure you're gonna come well
not very curious when you only left me
one voicemail message instead of your
usual 20 I'm trying to be a little less
intense and a little more considerate
here have a seat but only if you want to
okay I want to I never listened to what
you wanted or how you wanted us to be
when things ended between us I just
decided what I wanted and I got upset
when you didn't want the same thing I
know that's not fair and I'm very sorry
well thank you I appreciate that if you
don't want to have any more contact with
me I finally understand I don't want
that really but I just think it's for
the best okay okay
there is another option we could just
say screw it and do this thing for real
what I miss you like crazy I think about
you all the time I want to be with you
so let's just say screw it we would have
to tell Chris yeah I could turn into a
scandal if you hurt your campaign and
yeah how would how would you imagine we
do this I don't know but I I know how I
feel and I want to be with you but I'm
done steamrolling people this is how I
feel how do you feel weddings starting
soon how are things going I was just
ordained at WWE internet ministry
numeral for cheap calm but I'm having
some trouble with my speech I'll get so
far as a poem Oh sounds romantic
marriage is a contract between two
adults of different families
that's iku and a fact it works on two
levels it feels a little impersonal what
did the officiants say when you got
married not much when gay marriage was
legalized we weren't sure if or when it
was gonna be struck down so speed was of
the essence
do you Kevin yes and to you yes yes we
do we're married
I remark afterwards that I wished the
officiant had been more efficient it was
very funny Kevin still talks about it
maybe I should open with that zinger it
is amazingly funny I'm just not sure
this is the right crowd for no zinger
no I cool then I have nothing maybe I
should wing it love it sustains you it's
like
oatmeal okay okay
not bad for winging it I lied lead to
ours the right there
[Music]
hey hey it's me Andy you're an hour and
a half late I know I know I had to
massage a ton of feet super sorry come
on get in I need to do everything on
April's Lister she's not gonna go out
with me you're into April come on we'll
talk about in the car uh hold on I'll
get my books okay you're trying to lure
this young lady into your van yeah well
she's being really difficult about it
and it's actually not my van I stole it
from a friend of mine I technically
shouldn't be even driving because my
license is crazy expired that's Dwyer D
w-why II are dude come on
I gotta get out of here Natalie tell
this guy you know me do you fish April
no she shot gross let me give you a
piece of fishing advice I said I don't
when you have a fish on the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about maybe not
maybe you really do hate Andy maybe
moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know
[Music]
well yeah how did it go today is super
fun it was yeah do you have a list for
tomorrow you want to do this again
tomorrow
yes I do I mean it's a deal right I got
a do for a whole month and then you're
not gonna move to Indianapolis better be
the only person in kiss today damn I'm
positive that you are
you